Oh
waffles that I'm gonna go for my cakes
like breakfast over we're now gonna
publish today now the post of all is in
fact so massive that it's going to take
us several weeks to reach where our post
isn't it to be I'm writing the
atmospheric science aside
right
hang on what we need to do now is so Tom
told me through your poster what is this
we are very keen I should point out by
the way with very very are law abiders
this is a new in layman's terms that
like for YouTube what does that mean
this particular great stuff and then
this is my boy which you've already seen
yeah it's really cool to actually see it
live in a post of all that's real
research so we're now about to go after
the post the all's for the session
there's just poster session is about so
the same kind of science but talking
about it which convenient is about as
far away as it's possible to be while
still being at this conference
so whilst we've been on the very long
walk here we've been able to go puzzles
or lots of different sections and it's
worth pointing out that the diversity of
science here is incredible so we just
went past climate change solutions
forest ecology and you fellows lectures
into interest seasons the Decatur
climate variability remote sensing at
the cryosphere and this is all happening
5 days across the entire campus like
building from 8:00 until 5:00 or 6:00
just mind-boggling in that science is
already a few moments later the session
I was just in turned out to not be
terribly relevant because whilst it's
the session that my posters in that
particular all session was all about the
chemistry side the troposphere stuff
which isn't what I do and it isn't
doesn't have techniques which are
applicable so I'm not going to go over
see if I can get a petshop done the
professional place
program yes again so you can appear if
you up
all hail the Almighty Google will have
benevolent overlord so it turns out I
might be waiting for a while for a
hedgehog
I just had my makeup done
okay well I'm now gonna be late to the
next session and I smell of hairspray
but I do not have a free like
high-quality portrait hit shot on the
star of the show one of the things I
love about this conference is the sheer
variety of people you're not talking to
you so I just had a nice chat with the
girl in front of me in line he works in
the America modeling at all thermal
hydrodynamic systems who very much put
the jersey in New Jersey
lovely girl nice charity doing this now
got a rush over to the other side of it
sent cattle a talk to Topher gonna be a
bit more relevant than from the edges
you can see what accessibility finally
some relevant talks kind of they were
more relevant than previous talks anyway
and more importantly they were actually
good talks I haven't been terribly
impressed by the overall quality of
talks I've seen so far not to say that
it talks here generally of that but I
just the ones I've seen I haven't a very
impressed by but it was a really really
good talk or two in that session now
however I'm gonna go and watch Danes
talk he's giving a talk dusters
and again through three and Haeckel now
your diet I don't think how did it feel
for you but it was good it was the most
engaging talk I've seen here yeah now
you just say you seem very common in
control as well
by the way to learn to me we're off and
god
we're picking up our Star Wars tickets
because I don't know how to do this at
midnight
homo
oh hello oh these babies are like cut ha
these are so valuable to me emotionally
an educational you are having some
quality of sweet like regular people
ah yes right so now the way that this
works is everybody here has a poster
like me and basically we kind of mingle
and you stand by your poster and people
cannot to nautical questions about your
work and it's a very good opportunity to
network to probe your understanding of
what you've done but also you then get
to go mingle and talk to other people
and you get to learn about other
interesting bits of research sometimes
it's relevant research you do the long
time it is
in a move that has just proved my
never-ending did you fill atif I was
just talking to a lady about my poster a
nice lady put Susan Solomon recognize
who she was or the name is actually left
I asked her if she worked in the under
stratosphere you know her research she
saw swans and although I've dabbled
turns out that she explained the whole
new zone layer
she's a massive name she knows my
supervisors I'm not gonna live this down
behind me Tom's getting a bit more
attention than I
very interesting people just on someone
who is a space scientist but dealt with
started to be identical isotopes okay
down in touch after spirit and then in
SSW events and such and stratospheric
attending events propagates the top
space interesting are mister you know
it's a whole new makes people feel stuff
we didn't evolve on earth
pun so halfway through the poster
session we I just had a lovely chat with
some people from Oxford but it was
really nice having like an engaging chat
it's a weird mix about these things like
I suppose after a while it's half a
professional like and I mean the key to
get beer because it's free
hello people by my poster they just come
to harangue me you're the hero of the
hour really today though
well you mean you did a talk I'm just
setting and talking in front of poster
say 50 I did a really good job everyone
said you didn't
there's really short light
register there
goodbye
as opposed to session done for us the
posters are staying up we're off to
another session to go to talks okay so
we're leaving our posters to their own
devices we're off it's not typical that
you'd stay by helper post up the whole
time anyway that was I really enjoy yeah
it's like you know you need something
that you he spent so much time on the
project yeah it's nice to have somebody
to talk to about it who actually is
relatively technically capable
yeah and interesting yeah yeah I was I
was kind of dreading it in a way but
also I was looking forward to it and I
was I was right to the point to a lot of
fun yeah you know thanks a to you all I
found this in terms of spatial
positioning and special distribution on
the hemisphere of the circumpolar vortex
now that was a session life guarantee
that was I at least want all those
directly relevant to our research a
little bit guy here night how many 10
he'll break him to use non boundary
condition they lose inverting his pvq
that was really really good I'm actually
leaving one talk early to pick up a
personal now
strange old well I'm now going to a
meet-up people you tweet which of course
is known as a Twitter
goodbye old friend you serve me well
so we're at BP is down here bro chill
Astro pastor on Twitter I'm the relevant
boring James - if I need
roll it turns out Americans rock there's
quite strong one of the hardest
that's where we started
it's pretty good here I'd like liquid
see wasn't there
possession for me in this place I think
in the sense of size
okay so I decided I'm not going to go to
another brewery which has we had a few
drinks we have about three or four
drinks but for me three or four drinks
isn't normally a problem those were very
strong drinks like seven to nine percent
star drinks and if I went to another
brewery and had more drinks it would be
a bad idea so know your limits kids make
sure you stop to make a fool of yourself
I'm gonna go home to the hotel sober up
hopefully write a blog post and then
we're going to each other people on the
block then we're gonna wake up tomorrow
and not have regrets about things that
we have done or said other than things
that we might have done or said to our
girlfriend I'm sorry for watching this
those messages were totally legit I've
got to say if it was kind of weirdly
right like I don't feel awkward about
vlogging in the street here normally
when I walk for example in Vienna I felt
kind of awkward just walking out the
camera talking to but this is the home
of YouTube and Sam has this code where
people are
inherently self-obsessed to the point
where they've booked about themselves
like me I really like it
it feels very new age in a sense of its
embracing new technology but the same
time it does have the negative
connotation of new age that it embraces
new technology perhaps a little bit too
soon and as we were talking to other
people here everybody here is a CEO
everybody here is a founder everybody
here is all about trying to embody new
technology and the new ideas for that
necessary stop and think about what
those ideas mean
I think that my channel isn't quite so
vacuous as to have that problem but well
no easy to tell with you on the other
side is it in a somewhat worrying time
events behind me but I can't see it like
them there there's a queue for people
who are going to see all Star Wars films
in a row in a marathon I wanna a.m. I
don't think they see episode 7 respect
but I can wait until midnight tomorrow
it's like 26 hours and I get to see any
stat what's gone
the idea is very exciting now that layer
between ten kilometers and fifty calms
announced you is what we call the
stratosphere and it accounts for almost
the entirety of the remaining mass of
the atmosphere
see ya let's see if I can remember this
or if you want more bunch of videos with
John and I just talking about stuff then
please comment below make sure you go
and look at that singing playlist of
choral music about Christmas comment
below with what Peters your favorite you
know just have a listen to a few on
shuffle